the individual that was seen here on the
beach this morning was an
african-american male approximately six
six over 240 pounds
former WWE star shad gaspard was found
dead on a Venice Beach after going
missing earlier this week et can confirm
it match the description of the missing
swimmer that had gone missing during the
rescue efforts that we conducted here on
Sunday afternoon
the LA County coroner has identified the
body found on Venice Beach as shads
Los Angeles Fire Department's Brian
Humphrey said that officers were called
to lifeguard tower 26 located on Venice
Beach at about 1:45 a.m. on Tuesday
night after a man was found lifeless by
two people 15 minutes prior the body was
found about a half-mile north of where
shad was last seen shad went missing on
Sunday during a swim at Venice Beach
with his 10 year old son
the two were reportedly among a group of
swimmers caught in a strong rip current
according to reports lifeguards raced
into the water to pull everyone out
including shad son one witness at the
scene told TMZ that shad directed
rescuers to help his son first and
reportedly another big wave crashed down
on shad and he was not seen again the 39
year old pro wrestlers wife's Ileana
shared this pic of her husband on her
instace Tori asking fans to message her
directly if they had any info adding we
want to know if he's been seen and we're
on Tuesday the gas barred family issued
a statement thanking everyone for their
support quote shad is a fighter a
warrior and a magical soul we are hoping
and praying for his safe return please
continue to keep sending your positivity
and prayers to our beloved shad
Schad was a big star with the WWE back
in the day making up one half of the tag
team crime time with his partner JTG
take what you deserve and don't let
people like Jay T G stand in your way
over the last few weeks shad and silly
Anna had been doing what lots of married
couples have been doing during
quarantine tick-tocking this said we've
both been dancing all this time and shad
shared this message with fans hey buddy
just want to send you guys a message and
you know it's 10 try to calm down relax
now you say father
[Music]